twas the night before Christmas when all
through our home not a creature was
stirring but CNN's known at Wolf Blitzer
breaking news happening now I'm build
this house it with my own hands police
and prosecutors came armed with a
lawsuit against the house itself it was
being forfeited the stockings were hung
by the family tree in hopes that Saint
Nick would come visit philly the
children were nestled all snug in their
beds except my wayward son a sugarplum
head with Mama in her kerchief and I in
my cap he snuck to the porch and sold 40
bucks of smack then out on the lawn
there arose such a clatter I sprang from
my bed to see what was the matter
downstairs to the entrance I flew like a
flash a yellow police the front door was
smashed when what to my wondering eyes
did appear but cops with guns drawn not
a single reindeer one arrested my son so
lively and quick I knew in a moment he
was not Saint Nick more rapid than
Eagles my house they did sees how can
you do this I stated from my knees it's
called civil forfeiture fellows a cop
I'll take what I want and I'm not gonna
stop a wink of his eye and a twist of
his head soon gave me to know I had so
much to dread in just Philly alone in
just ten years time one thousand private
homes are now mine all mine the grip of
a rifle he held tight beneath the laser
sight circled my heart like a wreath his
scope how it twinkled framed on my dog
Thor he kicked up my family padlocked
our door loitering jaywalking BS traffic
stops all excuses to rob you cuz we're
the cops TVs cash cars galore everything
is fair game and he whistled and shouted
and
by name tick church funds tick shark
fins tick crosses SUVs by vipers buy
hookers by drones and Zamboni's to the
billions we seized with no charges at
all now dash your hopes stash your ID
stash away all then with that last word
he went straight to his work and stole
all the stockings then turned with a
jerk and laying his finger aside of his
nose and giving a snort he said sucks
your son blows he sprang to his cruiser
has his team he advised the rest of our
wish list will cease from good guys and
I heard him exclaim ere they drove out
of sight happy Christmas to all on to
the next house tonight it's kind of like
pennies from heaven you know it gets you
a toy or something that you need is a
way typically look at